We're told to find the x- and
y-intercepts for the graph of
this equation: 2 y plus
1/3x is equal to 12.
And just as a bit of a
refresher, the x-intercept is
the point on the graph that
intersects the x-axis.
So we're not above or below
the x-axis, so our y value
must be equal to 0.
And by the exact same argument,
the y-intercept
occurs when we're not to the
right or the left of the
y-axis, so that's when
x is equal to 0.
So let's set each of these
values to 0 and then solve for
what the other one has
to be at that point.
So for the x-intercept,
when y is equal to
0, let's solve this.
So we get 2 times 0, plus
1/3x is equal to 12.
I just set y is equal to
0 right there, right?
I put 0 for y.
Well, anything times 0 is just
0, so you're just left with
1/3x is equal to 12.
To solve for x, you can think of
it as either dividing both
sides by 1/3, or we can multiply
both sides by the
reciprocal of 1/3.
And the reciprocal of 1/3 is 3,
or you can even think of it
as 3 over 1.
So times 3 over 1.
And so we're left with 3 times
1/3, that just cancels out, so
you're left with x is equal
to 12 times 3, or
x is equal to 36.
So when y is equal
to 0, x is 36.
So the point 36 comma 0 is on
the graph of this equation.
And this is also the
x-intercept.
Now, let's do the same thing
for the y-intercept.
So let's set x equal 0, so you
get 2y plus 1/3, times 0 is
equal to 12.
Once again, anything
times 0 is 0.
So that's 0, and you're just
left with 2y is equal to 12.
Divide both sides by 2 to solve
for y, and you're left
with y is equal to
12 over 2, is 6.
So the y-intercept is when
x is equal to 0 and
y is equal to 6.
So let's plot these
two points.
I'll just do a little hand-drawn
graph, and make it
clear what the x- and the
y-intercepts are.
So let me draw-- that's my
vertical axis, and that is my
horizontal axis-- and we have
the point 36 comma 0.
So this is the origin right
here, that's the x-axis,
that's the y-axis.
The point 36 comma 0 might
be all the way over here.
So that's the point
36 comma 0.
And if that's 36, then the
point 0, 6 might be right
about there.
So that's the point 0, 6.
And the line will look
something like this.
I'm trying my best to draw
a straight line.
And notice where the line
intercepted or intersected the
y-axis, that's the y-intercept,
x is 0, because
we're not to the right
or the left of it.
Where the line intersected the
x-axis, y is 0, because we're
not above or below it.